hello
my name is brenton ashworth i work for
cognitect
formerly relevance and this talk is
about web applications
is there a ring web applications in
closure
and closure script with pedestal i
apologize for the really long title
and the ambiguity of the title uh when i
submitted this talk
i wasn't quite sure where pedestal would
be and it's changed quite a lot
since uh since i submitted the talk so
just to make it clear where we're going
i'm pedestal has two parts it has a
service part and a client part
during this talk we're going to focus on
the client side of pedestal
and it's designed to build a certain
kind of application we're going to take
a look at the kind of application that
it will help you build
and we're going to look at an example
application that we built for a client
and then after seeing that and having a
good example in our heads we'll take a
look at how we use pedestal to build
that example
and then we're going to take a look at
the future
there are a lot of interesting things
happening right now and we're trying to
incorporate
a lot of new ideas into pedestal
so if i could pick one word to describe
the kind of application that pedestal is
designed to help you build it would be
interactive applications
and specifically this definition that
you see up here this partial definition
applications which require that there be
a continuous two-way transfer of
information
a lot of the applications that we've
worked on at relevance in the last
two years that i've been there have been
this kind of application
and we found that we need something to
help us out
if you decide to make this kind of
application there's a lot of
implications for how you need to think
about developing it
and even the artifacts that you'll
create
we can no longer just assume that the
person sitting in front of the screen
using the application is going to be the
only source of events that we need to
respond to
or react to in the user interface
we receive inputs and events from
multiple sources
and we need to somehow coordinate all
this information into a coherent picture
and display it reasonably to the user
and this requires that we do
coordination now on the client
that we used to just do on the server
and so we need something to help us out
there when we do this on the server we
have a database
and we usually do all our coordination
there and when we have a lot of state
and a lot of events coming into the
client we need something
to kind of play that role
these applications don't really have
like a clear page reload boundary so
they run for a long time
that means they're usually larger and
and large from a code perspective they
do more
and it's a it's a lot more code so
we need to actually apply real
engineering effort into making these
applications to make sure that they run
well
and uh and don't die on us
so why in the world are we creating
something new
we need something besides just a
language languages are important and we
like closure script
for these kinds of applications but in
any
like endeavor we usually use libraries
to help us out
and we think that something is needed
here
and we
later in the talk you'll see some of the
things that i think
we need and how we implement those in
pedestal
also there are a lot of existing
libraries that we could use
but i think that from our standpoint
they either aren't well suited for
building this kind of application
or they rely heavily on mutation and
they have a lot of object-oriented
concepts which i think
unnecessarily complicate things
so we want to build something that is
more functional and will allow us to
program in the way that we're used to
enclosure even when we're in
in the browser and making large
applications in the browser
so the first thing we're going to do is
take a look at an example
application something that we built for
a client we had a client that came to us
and asked us to build
a a way to visualize
their sales funnel and they wanted to
see
in near real time how people are
progressing through the funnel
and how and if there's any problems how
they could
they would be able to see how they could
deal with those problems in real time
and the system needs to support
receiving about a thousand events per
second
from uh from the system that it lives
within
and uh it
even though it's getting a thousand
events per second it's it's updating the
browser about twice a second
so this is a very high level overview of
the architecture of the whole system
i just wanted us to see how uh the thing
that i'm going to show you fits into the
rest
we have a system that we deploy on aws
if you go from left to right we have
collectors which are
polling or having data pushed to them
they're putting that data on a queue
we have aggregators pulling data off the
queue and doing some
processing and sticking that data into
datomic and then we have an analyzer
which is being notified whenever new
data arrives in daytonic and then
pulling the new data out
rolling it up and sending updates to the
browser twice a second
and so i'm going to show you a
screenshot of the application and
explain what all the pieces are and then
we're going to run it
so hopefully you can see that and
what we have is we have the states that
people could be
in and each state the size of the circle
representing the state represents the
number of people in the state
around each one we have a donut that
tells us how many people
are instantaneously arriving in the
state versus leaving the state
the paths tell us how people traverse
between states and the bubbles
going along the path are telling us how
uh
how many people right now are traveling
between the states
and then paths on the top above the
circles
represent forward motion through the
states and then paths on the bottom
represent
backward motion and if you look over
there's one state that's
got like a little bit of blood dripping
out of it and that represents
people dropping out of that state so
we've also got some charts that show us
the number of uh users currently
in the funnel and how many how much
inventory we're selling
and errors and then at the bottom we
have
the history of each state so i'm going
to show you
two versions of this one that works and
one that doesn't work
so well so we're feeding data
into the visualization and we're feeding
data
once every five seconds to start with
and we're going to ramp up to
uh once or twice a second so you can
kind of see how it uh how it works as we
as we progress so it will order order
the states
as data arrives in the way that makes
the most sense this is a pretty simple
flow everybody's just moving through the
states in order
and we can see that the thicknesses of
the lines represent
how many people are actually traveling
between each state and what we're going
to see here is that the if you can see
the um
the labels the shipping state is
actually getting larger
it's getting clogged and we can see that
there's a big blue donut and a little
bit of orange that means that
there's a lot of people arriving in that
state and not a lot of people leaving
and so maybe the person watching this
would get on the phone and somebody
would push some buttons
and somehow solve this problem
we can also see that uh that sales is
kind of suffering up there we've dropped
off because not a lot of people are
making it clear through
to the confirmation state and now we've
we've added some new ways to traverse
the through the states
people can skip over shipping now
so anyway that's just a simulation to
show you how it works
don't be afraid of all those errors up
there it's uh it's just a simulation
normally that much wouldn't be going
wrong
so i want to show you one version of
this that doesn't work so well
and we'll see if we can see how it
doesn't work
so it's the same exact code it's just
running in a different way
and we're going to start sending
messages once every five seconds and
then ramp up to twice a second
can you see this by the way yeah okay
so uh what you see here is there's a
pretty significant pause and that pause
is happening whenever
we get an update and we have to process
the data and figure out
what to do with it so i don't know how
many of you have run into this kind of
problem when you have a lot of
animations in the browser
and you're trying to do other work it
can be kind of tough to figure out how
to solve it and sometimes we have to
resort to
breaking up our code into all these
pieces with timeouts between them in
order to
make this run smoothly so that's the
demo
so this is what we're trying to build
and there's really two hard problems
here
how do we draw this stuff that's hard
and pedestal doesn't help you with that
and then how do we control it there's a
lot of state that we're getting in the
browser a lot of messages
and there's a lot of things to control
on the screen and even
what's visible on the screen and how do
we do that
and that's the part that pedestal helps
us with
so what we did on this project is we
divided the work into these two main
categories we
uh we used raphael for the for the
animations and we used high charts for
some of the charts
and we created widgets we wrapped these
things into
self-contained pieces of code that we
could add to the page and remove
and each one had a simple api so we
could send data to it
control it for example we could set we
could tell the big
a chart you know make this state a
certain size or this path a certain size
and that all that code was actually
written in javascript we had people
working on this project with
different skill sets and so the people
that were help some of the people
helping with
uh with the widgets didn't know closure
script so
we just wrote these in javascript so we
have widgets and we can we can they can
draw the things that we want to draw
but none of these things have any kind
of application state in them
they just draw draw things on the screen
so we need to be able to control them we
need to be able to determine when these
things should be displayed
and and that's what pedestal helps us do
so pedestal at least in the context of
this project
provides at least four things that
helped us out it provide
provides a clear separation of concerns
it provides an information model we're
going to look at these one at a time
it provides an information model a state
transition model and data flow
so what do we mean by separation of
concerns
the thing that pedestal does that i
think is very helpful is that it
uh it clearly separates these three
things rendering
from your information model and logic
and services and what i mean here by
services
is the part of your application that
does communication with the back end so
this might be the part that's got like
an ssl
an sse connection or a
web sockets or is making http requests
to the back end
we want to isolate that because it's it
can be very complex and if you let that
get intermixed with everything else
you're going to have problems and then
the same with rendering we want to keep
that isolated as much as possible
these two places rendering and services
this is where all the complexity
of programming in the browser exists
so we want to keep these things uh keep
those isolated
and then in our information model and
logic that is where all the
the application logic for our
application lives that's where the state
lives
and that's really very simple it's it's
data it's data transformation
and this is the kind of this is the kind
of thing that closure is really good at
we can we can run this code
on in the browser we can run it uh on
enclosure to test it that makes testing
very easy
so anyway how do we how do we separate
these things
we separate them with messages and cues
so
there's no way to well you can probably
call across them but if you want to use
pedestal you
communicate between these parts by using
by sending messages
and you send messages on cues we don't
make direct function calls across these
boundaries
some messages just give us a way to
communicate without making function
calls and then cues
sever the direct connections so even if
we if we didn't have queues but we had
messages we'd still be
determining when things run queues give
us the ability to kind of step away from
that
and these cues are not real cues they're
javascript style cues
they're kind of simulated cues basically
an array and uh and asynchronous
processing
of that array cues also give us the
ability to
independently process the data on the
queue
so we can take a look at our application
and if the queue backs up we can decide
we're going to start dropping stuff or
we can maybe compact things
and it's it's very nice to have them
i just wanted to show you an example of
the
the kinds of messages that we would use
i'm not going to go into
the details of these messages but i just
wanted to give you an idea of what they
look like
the top message is the kind of thing
that we would send into our application
and the bottom two are the kinds of
things that might go out to the renderer
and we would these would be mapped to
functions which perform
some uh small change in what we're in
what we're rendering
and so in this application we use
widgets the functions that receive these
messages
would maybe make an api call to a widget
to make it to make a small change
notice that there is a similarity
between these messages even though
they're slightly
different they all have an operation
something we want to do
they have a target the thing that we
want to do it to and then they have
arguments
and in the future this is actually going
to get standardized a bit
so next we'll look at the fact that
pedestal has an information model and
what i mean by this specifically
is is that we have a standard way to
organize and store data
if you if you didn't have this you could
you could store data however you'd like
or
organize your data however you'd like
but if you do that you can't really
leverage
leverage that you can't build things on
top of it so having some kind of
standard
helps us out it's kind of like in a
database you have schemas and you talk
about types and that allows the database
to
do things more efficiently so
the way that we store data is in a tree
and you can just think of this as
nested maps that tree contains
the basis information that we might
receive
from other sources that talk about you
know things that we know these the facts
that we
that we have learned about we have
derived information things that we
derive from the basis information
and we have some information that
supports
the ui so uh
that's what we put in our data model or
our information model
so this is what it might look like this
is a true representation of that it's a
tree
we see the nodes but we don't really see
the values in the tree
the thing that this allows us to do is
talk about talk about
nodes in the tree using paths so the one
that you see on the bottom there
is a path to a specific node and we
might use that to say
i want to update that subtree and the
top
message has a wild card in it we might
use that to
say that we would like to be notified if
one of the children of the devices node
is changed
these are just the way that we can refer
to nodes in the tree
and this is an example of one thing that
we can have if we assume that there's a
certain structure to our data
so another thing that we have are state
transitions a state transition model and
what i mean by this is that there's just
there's some way
to have an orderly succession of states
our application state is stored in one
one big tree and we want to know that
when there's an input
we're going to have a new tree a new
state and we want to know that we're
progressing between states in an orderly
way we're not
updating things in a random fashion
or out from under us um
we also want to be able to associate
cause and effect
so something happened we now have a new
state
i want to be able to associate those two
things here's the cause here's the
message that came in here's the new
state that that produced that's
extremely valuable for
testing
so if you've written applications in
closure script you may have
you you may have used an atom for this
type of thing
it's it's well suited for this and some
of the implementations
of our transition model use an atom
if you're not familiar with closure an
atom is a reference type it allows you
to
draft it and get a value an immutable
value
and you can send functions to it perform
state trans transitions
those are atomic state transitions you
can also add a watcher
to the atom and then the watcher
function will be called whenever
the atom changes and get the old and new
value
and so we can use this to store state
and be notified when that state changes
but one of the problems that you run
into is you start to ask yourself how
many atoms do i need to use
it's nice to have everything in one atom
because you have all your state there
and you have consistent updates
but as that data gets larger and larger
and larger
it's harder to tell what you've changed
so if you get a big
if you get you change one thing you have
a lot of data that now you have to
figure out where's that one thing that i
changed
so we would like to have the best of
both worlds and that's what pedestal
gives us it gives us a way to
consistently move between states
and we have fine-grained change
reporting so you can keep all your state
in one thing
and you can watch for specific parts of
that thing
and be notified when those when that
part changes
so dataflow is another thing that
pedestal provides
it allows us to disconnect functions
from how they're executed
and what this means is that we we can
declaratively say here are the inputs to
this function
and here's what should happen with the
output and
then the engine that's running our
application
can decide when that function needs to
be run it will do that based on what has
changed in the data so we specify
declaratively the positions in the data
that we
that we're actually watching and um
when those positions change when those
nodes change
the function is called and we get an
update so this
allows us to atomically propagate
changes through our automatic
sorry automatically propagate changes
through
through our data model this is all based
on the data model
so we're not actually tying together
function
inputs and outputs we change the data
model
we call a function that updates the data
model and then another function may be
called if it's watching
the output of the previous function so
this is all centered around
the data model itself it allows us to
avoid writing explicit pub sub
code or big hairy conditionals
so some of the advantages of dataflow is
that it's a great way to
encode the dependencies between data in
uis and ui applications these can be
quite complex
something like i click a button i want a
menu to be a menu item to be disabled
and i want maybe some other menu items
to show up
we can we can do all that with data flow
and it's actually a nice way to do it
it also promotes adding code rather than
updating code which i think is nice
you can usually write very small focused
functions
that are that are part of the data flow
and if you need to do something new
instead of finding the conditional
that you need to update and going in and
updating some big nasty confusing thing
you can add a new
uh a new function to the data flow
so what we're going to do now is walk
through how the data flow would actually
work to give you a better idea
of how this works in the upper left hand
corner we have
our view this is going
to something's going to happen in the
view to generate an event
and then the callback for that event is
going to
transform that event into a message and
put it on a queue
so that green arrow is a message on a
queue
and then what we do is we find a
function that handles that
that particular message that function
runs and it updates a part of our
subtree
and even though it operates on a
specific subtree the
thing that it changes might just be the
phone node
of that selected subtree
and then the visible node the blue one
down at the bottom it
depends on selected so if that selected
changes we want
the visible subtree to change so
the dataflow engine will will know that
that changed and know that that function
depends on it and that function has two
inputs it cares about both the selected
subtree
and the devices subtree
and those will be passed into this
function it will produce a new value for
the visible
subtree and what that will do is update
the review
node and so on
we update the order node and then
finally what we end up with
is these are the things in the tree that
we actually changed
and in between each of these steps we
generate a change report that tells us
what what actually changed at the end of
this process we would have something
that might
look like this these are things that
actually changed in the tree
and then we can use that to match match
patterns later on and find functions
that may care about that or
or when we're finished with the complete
state transition
we would get this report out and we can
do something with it
so another way to look at this is to
think about what a round trip looks like
if something happens in the view
how does that work its way through the
system and actually update the view
so again we have an event and we have a
message on a queue
and then the screen box represents
finding a function
to handle that message and then the
black arrow there
is basically taking the return value of
that function that we found
and applying it or using that to replace
some part of our information model
and then uh the the info model has
changed
so we get a change report which is the
orange dotted line there
and the same thing we find a um we find
a function that cares about that
the return value updates the data model
and these run until we're finished
and then when we're finished we have a
change report
coming out the other side and we find a
function that is going to generate
the data that we're going to send up for
rendering
and we have a renderer that guy is going
to
going to find a function that handles
each message and make a change to the
view so that might be
like a fine grain change to the dom or
it might be a call to an api so in this
case we're controlling widgets
so we're calling some function on our
widget api
so the reason why the in the example
that i showed you there were two
versions of the application one of them
that didn't work so well and one that
did
and the reason why the one that did work
so well uh worked is because
because we've we've separated rendering
from all of our application logic
we can run them in different places so i
can run uh
all of the application logic in the data
flow
i can run it in closure for testing i
can run it in a web worker
and we already have a way to communicate
across the across
the boundary between between the web
worker
thread and the main javascript thread
and so that's how that application runs
everything about the application runs in
a web worker
and rendering happens on the main
javascript thread
and so i have to say it was pretty nice
being able to program in the browser
with real parallelism
so that's how that works that's at least
an overview of how it works
so then uh while we were working on this
uh i think when this project started uh
the project that we did for the client
that was about the exact same time that
core async was started
and it finished about the time when we
finished this project
and if you're ever working on something
and rich hickey
starts working on something related to
what you're doing you should probably
just
wait and see how that's going to affect
what you're doing
because because it can disrupt you
so we have all these things how many
people here went to rich's talk and know
what core async is okay so
almost everybody uh core async i'm not
going to really cover
all the all the things that corey gives
you but basically it provides channels
so these are like more like real cues
not like the fake ones that we're using
and it allows us in the browser to
program as if we had
threads so we can have real processes
that are communicating with each other
and we can block which is amazing in the
browser you can actually sit there
block on a on a channel and it's not
going to keep the rest of your code from
running
and so there are some huge advantages
here
and we want to have these advantages as
well as some of the ones that we already
have
in in pedestal so if you think about
some of the diagrams that i showed you
there's a couple problems
in those diagrams a couple problems that
we have in pedestal right now
one of them is that if you look at the
way we process
messages going from some kind of event
happening or something changing
to some value that might change our
information model or affect something
else
we have this basic pattern that we that
we go through
we have a change come in some sort of
novelty either a change to our info
model
or a new message so it's something new
and then we have a way
to take a map of
patterns to functions and find a
function
that handles one of those changes or
cares about one of those changes
we we call that function and then we get
something we get a return value or we
get a message that we put
on some kind of a queue and so we're
doing things in a couple of different
ways which could be unified
and the way that we plan to unify them
with core async is to
think about having two different kinds
of channels a channel that we'll call an
inform channel
that carries messages which describe
something something about the source
that changed so this is a way for a
source to say
i have changed in this way so we'll send
a message an inform message and that
will have
an ad an identifier for the source in
some kind of state
and then we can do the same thing that
we're doing now we can have patterns
that match those changes
find functions to handle them or that
care about them
call those functions and instead of
returning
whatever they want to return they will
return
transform messages so transform messages
are very much like the messages that i
showed earlier
they have an operation they have a
target and they have arguments
and uh a transform message is saying
here's how i would like you to change so
we have these two sides right
here's how i changed and here's how i'd
like you to change and so i want to walk
through
how we can make pedestal
from these kinds of channels so again
we're going to do
we're going to go through the whole
process we have a view
an event occurs what we're going to do
is
take that callback and that when we run
that callback we're going to take the
event and turn it into an inform message
so that message is going to tell us
something about how the thing
changed that we care about so this is
our inform channel in blue
and then we're going to find a function
based on that inform message
that cares about that and can transform
that into
a transform message on the data model
and instead of actually finding
a function here we're going to directly
apply it to the data model
if we know the path to the thing we want
to change
we know a way to automatically find the
function that we're referring to
and we know the arguments we can just
apply that uh with update in to the data
model
so we remove a step there
and then when we talk about the data
flow portion
of state transitions we can do that with
these same channels so we can have an
inform channel that tells us here's how
the information model changed
and we have a function that we found
which generates transforms that
and those get applied to the information
model
once this is finished we'll have the
final inform channel
coming out that that tells us how
the info model changed as we've gone
through the entire data flow
and then what we can do is we can find
here uh just like our emitter in the
previous example
we can find a function which will
generate uh the transformations that
must happen
to the user interface then finally
this is just like our renderer we can
find the uh
functions that actually make the changes
to the user interface based on those
transformations
if you think about this it's the same
separation except now we're using
channels
and we've got a few uh we've got fewer
parts
so another advantage that this gives
is that it allows us to um
use we can encapsulate changes in
widgets so if we
if we would like to not do the manual
message transformation and finding uh
functions
or or manually trans handling transform
message
messages by updating the ui we can
encapsulate that in widgets and so
in the application that we built we
could either write our own widgets
that was actually a nice way to handle
it or we could have reusable widgets and
i don't know if
any of you have looked at the work that
david nolan has been doing
like his example of the autocomplete
field that he created
that's the kind of thing that if we if
we made it aware of
transform messages and inform messages
we could just use that in our
application
as long as we have a sufficiently good
way to uh to customize it
and another thing to to know about
widgets is that
they may not just be valuable for the ui
maybe we could have
some that help us with parts of our of
the service
so that's pretty much it
thank you check out pedestal if you're
interested if anybody
uh would like to talk to me about this
i'd be happy to talk to you if anybody
thinks this is a good or bad idea
just come and talk to me i would love to
to especially hear
people who think this is a bad idea so
uh are there any are there any questions
yes
well if uh i think we want to make some
kind of api so that you could have
javascript widgets
that would um that would actually plug
into this
i don't think that's actually going to
be a problem we want to support that
definitely yes
kyle so uh if i understand right a
really the key advantage of the current
model
is that almost all your logic system
little functions are very easy to test
you lose any of that by having them
wired up before it's angry now you have
to set up
you know set up message flow to test
your logic versus just it's just the
function
you don't because the functions
themselves wouldn't
really be aware of the core async stuff
so the engine is wiring up the functions
and the engine is responsible for
creating like the pipeline that's going
to run your code
so the functions themselves wouldn't
necessarily need to be aware
of core async unless you wanted to
have a function that returned a channel
which is actually one of the advantages
of this
you could have a function in your data
flow that
if you if you had a sufficiently fast
like api that you wanted to call
it's much easier to write the straight
line code that calls that api and blocks
and you could just return a channel that
would then when when you read from the
channel it would get the response the
result instead of
returning immediately so that's actually
one of the advantages of this
the functions normally shouldn't
shouldn't have to know
yes
uh i don't think it changes at all
because we still have messages that we
that define all the changes that we're
making and we can
store those messages and replay them
later with with a part of our
application i didn't really show that at
all we
because we're sending data sending
messages to a renderer to render we can
actually
record those messages and play them back
through the renderer
and that is very helpful when you're
making super complex uh
stuff in the ui and you have to maybe
have like
five people uh simulating like acting on
one thing it's easy to
like you can do that simulation one time
record the data and then run it over and
over again
to get the rendering just right but i
think we'll still be able to do that
kind of stuff
yes
it does actually yeah but web workers
are actually super
hard to work with normally you have to
[Music]
decide ahead of time which code is
actually running in the web worker and
there's
we added some support so that you can
configure your application to say
uh here's the stuff that i want to run
in the web worker and then when you
compile
it will automatically compile that stuff
into like its own file and load it in
the web worker
and there's even stuff for like making
the
going across the boundary like the
channels go across
the thread boundary yep but it is still
a little bit hard to use if you want to
know about that check out the tutorial
the very last section of the pedestal
tutorial
has uh has all the documentation for how
to how to do that
yes
so in the current in the current model
we can actually figure that out ahead of
time by looking at the inputs and
outputs we
we can figure what are the inputs and
what are the outputs of each function
that we run
and so we can order them and then run
them in order one time so we know we're
not going to get in an infinite loop
in the new version we would do like a
fixed point so we have to be careful
uh we'll have to be careful to just not
run forever and maybe
kind of throw some air if people do
something wrong right but
it'll be like a fixed point set up
anything else
okay uh yes
how did the choice of closure make this
project easier
well uh the whole project all of the
ideas in it
are based on like the ideas in closure
so
it's kind of a hard question to answer
because we wouldn't even have thought up
thought this if we weren't using closure
and so because we
we are so uh absorbed into those ideas
this is just this actually feels kind of
natural
so i guess that's the advantage is that
closure makes it feel natural
a lot of people uh think this is very
confusing but
i think for people who are really into
closure and
doing stuff on the ui i think that it is
actually
it feels quite natural anybody else
yes in the back
which which one
integrating uh
yeah we haven't looked into that in
detail yet so that's something that
we're going to be doing in the future
so no the answer to your question is no
i haven't looked into it
okay one more question and then we'll
wrap it up yeah the difference between
the two styles
could you just spend a second talking
about sort of the concern
between the two it seems like there's a
slight difference in the
end result right so you're saying here's
how i wanted you to
change yeah here's the thing that i'm
going to apply
and then the other one seems a bit more
like
i did a thing you there's
right so actually they're both uh
they're both actually the same
they just seem different um you're
always in the in the first model we are
saying here's how i want you to change
um sometimes we talk about it like
here's a change
react to it but really we're saying
here's how i want you to change
this
right yes so uh
it's i think what we're doing is we're
more we're being more clear about what
the roles of each part
are so all right thank you